it is said that until you take charge of
your own life things don't happen well I
did just that I wanted a better life for
myself and for my family so I took
charge and cracked an amazing job in
Canada I found a need to get more skills
and certification to stand out from the
crowd and I choose simply love as my
upskilling partner
I was even rewarded with a decent salary
hike after the completion of the course
hello
I am
I live in the beautiful City of Calgary
in Canada with my family and I have done
the business analyst master program from
Simply love
this program was a combination of
different things like SQL training C web
certification
ccab power bi Tableau a child training
and a couple of Hands-On projects that
we had to complete and score at least 80
percent
my main focus was on CB certification
though I am also certified with lean Six
Sigma Green Belt from TCS and now I am
preparing for the black belt my
experience with simply Runner was pretty
good the instructor were knowledgeable
query resolution was fast and I really
enjoyed the projects and the Practical
knowledge that I got while learning from
Simply I am also a registered member and
certified business analyst from iipa I
Feel Again more confident and become a
better business analyst after getting
this certification I feel that learning
is a crucial part of our life because if
we stop learning we stop our growth
I constantly try to learn new things by
reading books or reading our new
advancement in different Market sectors
online
actually my long-term goal is to become
a quality director and I feel upskilling
is the only way I would be able to
achieve that goal I think everyone
should keep upscaling because until you
take charge of your own life things
don't happen